guns have the timeout decide not to call
it
[ __ ] the drive gets inside leans in
knocked away and stolen by holiday
phoenix has to foul ball throws it down
and a foul giannis on the alley-oop
what a turnaround a chance to take the
lead and the turnover
as the bucks now up by three and a free
throw coming up
what a play by drew holiday gets into
the picture comes up with the strip
turning the basketball over and then off
to the races
could have held it out instead made the
right read throws it up where only
giannis can catch it
finishes it with the contact and bad
decision to foul because this would make
it
a four-point game with 13.5 remaining
phoenix still has a timeout
once again a critical free-throw for
giannis athena kupo
missed it fight for the rebound tipped
and taken by middleton
and they have to foul middleton with 9.8
remaining they couldn't secure the
defensive rebound
he missed so bad that it became
difficult to get the defensive rebound
it's the second offensive rebound
they've gotten tonight
off his miss and a back tap
and they get it to a great free-throw
shooter
[Music]
a heads-up player there from giannis now